una noche festiva en ramala estos
acudieron en masa al encendido de la
linterna del ramadán el mes sagrado
musulmán de ayuno o ración y meditación
comienza este jueves
nos alegramos pero nuestros corazones
hay una punzada con lo que está pasando
con los presos han anunciado una huelga
de hambre
operaciones mortales del ejército
israelí en sus Jordania ataques contra
civiles en Israel el aumento de las
tensiones en las últimas semanas está en
la mente de todos
a pesar de todo el sufrimiento y las
masacres en gaza el campo de yenín y
naulus y a pesar de los problemas que se
agravan con el encarcelamiento de
nuestros hermanos y hermanas les
enviamos un mensaje de esperanza y amor
estamos con ellos estamos aquí reunidos
a pesar del dolor pero difundimos
Esperanza
dentro de unos días los judíos
celebrarán pesa la Pascua judía y los
cristianos las fiestas de pascua en
Jerusalén la ONU pide un statu quo
estricto en los lugares Santos de las
tres religiones monoteístas los próximos
días podrían traer algo de calma Esa es
la esperanza de las Naciones Unidas y de